one of President Obama's closest
advisors is pulling back the curtain on
u.s. foreign policy during the Obama
administration Ben Rhodes was a
speechwriter during mr. Obama's 2008
presidential campaign after the election
he became deputy national security
adviser to the president he was closely
involved in key decisions on Syria Iran
and Cuba in his new book the world as it
is a memoir of the Obama White House
Rhodes takes us behind the scenes of the
biggest moments during the Obama
presidency Ben Rhodes is the brother of
CBS News president David Rhodes welcome
abend hey John let's start with North
Korea before we get to the book the
meeting is back on on the 12th I know
you're not a fan of president Trump's
but doesn't he deserve his due here and
getting this to where it's gotten so far
look I think diplomacy is preferable to
military conflict the question is what
is that diplomacy produce what I think
is most likely as you'll see the North
Koreans make commitments
denuclearize in the future but in the
past we've seen them make those
commitments did not follow through and
the follow through is a question John
let me turn to the book because starting
with with President Trump there's a line
that's already gotten a lot of press I
know this is about the entire
administration but let's start on this
comment from former President Obama what
if we were wrong what exactly does that
mean
well you know President Obama wasn't
unlike a lot of Americans after the
election he was trying to figure it out
and we went through different theories
was it the Russian meddling was it the
campaign that the Democrats ran and we
were on that last foreign trip and I was
sitting with him in his presidential
limousine and he'd read a column saying
you know maybe Democrats that pushed too
far in an embrace of kind of
globalization and had gotten away from
you know that sense of identity that
it's important to people part of which
was what you know President Trump in
stoked but I think frankly the reality
is any number of causal factors led to
president Trump and what I answer in the
book is that question which is I think I
don't think we were wrong
well actually what you say in the book
is that you should have seen it because
you said when you distilled it stripped
out the racism and misogyny we'd run
against Hillary eight years ago with the
very same message Trump had use she's
part of a corrupt estab
Bushman that can't be trusted to change
well I woke up the morning after
election night kind of shell-shocked and
and that's when it hit me you know that
that what he went on a change election
and a corrupt establishment well that
was his message the racism and misogyny
was also part of the message and that's
an important aura but I think you know I
remember election night sitting there in
my friend's apartment Cody Keenan who's
a speechwriter for President mama - and
president Alma called us to talk about
what he was going to say the next day
and we're all just absorbing this news
in this new reality and I do realize in
that moment that I don't think that we
had inhabited the the likelihood of
Trump winning that we you know we hadn't
put ourselves in that place and you had
that shell shock and then the next
morning you start to analyze it and
that's what I'm talking about there in
the book this line has been focused on
by critics of the president's President
President Obama because they say it
repeats a flaw that they've seen in him
throughout his public life which is that
what he meant in that question what if
we were wrong was not about his own
misperceptions but about the electorate
that the electorate was just too slow to
catch his kind of change and that that's
the that's the criticism people saying
then what's your response to them oh
absolutely not John I mean you know what
President mama said his entire political
career is that his bet was always on the
American people
he couldn't have become the first
African American president a two-term
president without the competence of the
American people you know I think what
he's getting at is a bigger phenomenon
in the world again we were on a trip
that led up to that comment that he made
where we saw Angela Merkel in Germany
who had taken a huge flack for letting
in Syrian refugees and literally had a
tear in her eye the last time she saw
President Obama we left Justin Trudeau
sitting there alone wondering what was
gonna happen with President Trump and
now we see we'd seen President Xi
Jinping of China who made common ominous
comment to us that if an immature leader
throws the world in the cast the world
will know who to blame and he was not
talking about President Obama and I
think what he's referring to there is a
sense of globalization of immigration
and trade that we're part of an
enterprise basically a liberal
international order that had pushed very
far at changing the the nature of our
world over the last several decades and
that that the question is did that get
too far ahead of voters in places like
the United States in the United Kingdom
you know who were feeling a sense of
uncertainty because of that change this
book was so personal to me it seemed to
me about you Ben I mean you really
talked about your place in the
administration questioning your what you
were doing there when do you fit in and
being a speechwriter for some of the
most iconic speeches how do you write
for someone that you really didn't know
very well and how you navigated those
waters yeah I mean what I really wanted
to try to convey to readers I was 29
years old when I worked for Brock Obama
I didn't have a plan to be the deputy
national security adviser I wanted to
help them get elected president and I
remember you know you get this great
opportunity to write for this guy it was
a great order but you know I didn't
really know him and so what I did is I
spent you know weeks listening to all of
his interviews trying to get inside his
voice he wrote a very revelatory book
dreams to my father that I must have
read several times and I could lift from
that and put you know passages and
speeches but ultimately you know you
have to forge a connection with the guy
who you're working for and I had some
good opportunities on that campaign to
get close to him you said we didn't
always get things right but the larger
project of believing that America is a
better place when you look at the Trump
administration many people believe that
they're trying to unravel and undo
everything that the Obama administration
did does he feel that way and do members
of the administration feel that
everything that you did the work that
you accomplished that they're now trying
to take it all apart do you feel that
well certainly there are certain
policies that they've targeted you know
Paris climate agreement Cuba TPP there's
not an ideological rationale for why you
would take down all those policies other
than that Barack Obama did them but
again it comes back to the what if we
were wrong question
the you know look I say look we didn't
get everything right and I show I say
that there are things I still don't know
I'm not certain about I'll be think
about the rest of my life I'm sure I'll
be thinking about decision making on
Syria the rest of my life but the fact
that America is a progressive inclusive
country that has a future that is more
inclusive and more diverse that I truly
do believe in frankly I think that
project of the Obama presidency that
will endure for decades that's the
direction America is headed and that's
not the direction that Donald Trump is
headed so I think when history has its
accounting here
America is going to end up looking a lot
more like the Obama presidency than the
trump presidency all right Ben Rhodes
congratulations on the book the world as
it is goes on sale tomorrow